so what was it the other day
um
they had the
uku versus usa the youtube boxing thing
a few people messaged me asking us to do
like a a breakdown on this thing the
event as a whole i'm gonna throw out you
now
shambles um
in terms of like production organization
yeah bro just them man oh really just
dead man just fam
this whole
era of
youtubers or influencers or just social
media personalities boxing is a [ __ ]
joke i'm with you
it took me a long money grab button it's
a money grab
now it needs to stop being even that
yeah jake paul's done his team yeah and
he's he's a he's he's doing well now
yeah i'm not even including him in this
thing anymore he's actually a good boxer
he's he's a quality fighter now he's
he's broken through the mould
and he's doing his damn thing so props
to him yeah bro
this thing that i saw on the weekend was
a [ __ ] joke really but i had to write
notes on the fights that i saw alright
hit me bro bro so first off
okay cool
so the first one
there's a brother called you would have
seen him on tick tock is a bear called
salt puppy
van this brother this this running guy
yeah he had a fight with his other
brother called neva
yes
he this is what i'm saying to you bro
that's what i'm saying i thought man was
there just doing like a rantic not even
a
not even a ranting probably just there
to like show face talk to people
no he wasn't so he was fighting and at
the beginning of his first starters he
was fighting a brother called halal ham
oh my god so it's like tick-tock
tick-tock yeah fam at the beginning of
the thing
they had some breda trying to run bars
on salt papi okay he must have been
working with these american dons okay
because he's running bars on salt puppy
racist as [ __ ] oh swear this is what i'm
saying darting was a shambles bro he's
running bars like oh i'm butchering it
but man said saturn like
um i don't know ah i didn't even know
what he said but basically he was just
saying some basically said something
along the lines of you must be [ __ ]
chinese because your eyes are sunk in
and this whole baby bear's like filipino
or something he's from asian descent
yeah from they had to get a brother
while he's in the middle of the
basically imagine some puppies here
there's halal brothers here and in the
middle of the ring for what i don't know
who
said this was allowed in the middle of
the ring there's this guy just trying to
run bars yeah and he's just saying
racist [ __ ] someone had to come into the
middle of his little [ __ ] rhyme
had to come in and be like big man
you're being seriously [ __ ] racist
like shut the [ __ ] up
and then do like oh sorry sorry sorry
and then just carry on and then he and
then he threw some kind of [ __ ] likes
sweet and sour chicken bar in there as
well and then just wrapped it oh my
goodness bro shambles embarrassing
so you can who's this bread oh my
goodness
who's this brett um what made didn't
make eat what made even less sense is
this supposed to be some uk versus usa
team there's not bobby bread as uk yeah
but the bread running bathroom is from
the uk is it english day so i was i was
confused about the whole scenario
i'm assuming so i didn't hear him speak
but yeah i think he's from the u.s okay
fam anyway
this halal brother got tumped to
smithereens
bro
this allowed brother got time to
smithereens yeah he was done was it not
necessarily a good fight but did they
have like good posture and like throwing
good punches
all right
they were using these
stupid [ __ ] gloves stupid how they
were just big they were like training
sparring gloves okay but for like
they're they're the type of gloves that
you can buy from like [ __ ] sports
direct like they i don't know why they
were using these gloves bro okay um but
anyway they were like some [ __ ] 20
ounce gloves some massive soft gloves
and anyway so they're doing a team
sock puppy just pap pap pap pap like
pep in him pep in him and then the bread
was also fat and knack
the halal bread yeah fat and yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so he was trying to grips
him any chance he could get grips in him
hold that fast salt would dash him
at one point the guy was so twist up he
was basically laying on some puppy's
chest yeah somebody looked at his corner
yeah
basically like
like it was a black panther thing yeah
is this your king
you looked at him he lifts you looked at
them stuck his tongue out and was like
are you sure
is this the brother you've been hyping
this bright oh my god stroking his head
everything
it was embarrassing that fight
embarrassing for the u.s fair enough
this halal brother got
tumped to pieces and was shattered
so that was the first fight i saw and
apart from this little racist encounter
at the beginning i thought okay cool bro
there was one brother who fought i can't
remember who he thought one english
brother
joke his name was ryan taylor youtuber
called ryan taylor
okay for some reason oh i think in a
range of rings above i don't know head
butted the claw out of his um opponent
head bite fan you see how
you see our boxing
sometimes head butts happen just head
clashes yeah these mine are in the
clinch and it's just a little knock of
the head yeah yeah
my man was in the clinch
pulled back
like here yeah that nutted him in his
face
from distance no he never i promise you
he did oh my goodness peel back and
nutted him in his face
did he drop him no the bread was just
like what was gay
i know the rules today
yo
embarrassing fight done or they were
just disappointed oh i didn't i
i don't know if they continue i didn't
watch the rest of that i'm thinking [ __ ]
this guy jesus embarrassing i don't know
where the [ __ ] it was so there was there
was no disguise in it bro there was no
clash of heads he literally gave him a
pub nut
pub he gave him a good solid pa-pow fam
it was the most humiliating thing i've
ever seen
joke man it's ryan taylor brother never
don't know what he does what content he
does joke man
he's from the uk as well joke man
joke man head button brother's in a
professional setting joke man you're
embarrassing yourself the next fight i
saw was deji so now now we're talking
ksi's barbie deji versus alex wasabi
okay
cool
i felt bad for deji
because i remember when did you four
jake paul i'm sure paul yeah this is
when ksl was ksi the logan thing yeah
and this was him at b for now we're not
people we were in ibiza
um [ __ ] me and um
yeah so
i remember what did you look back then
shocking
fight style back then technique shocking
okay and so was jake paul to be fair
back then and i remember thinking all
right desi let's see and then i'm in
their press conference
apparently alex was chatting up i think
alex must be a fan of ksi or something
because he keeps chatting so
deji pulls out some press conferencing
and says oh i know you're a fan of my uh
brother and my brother does a lot of
performances so he keeps a towel with
him more time i managed to get him to
sign this sweaty towel for you you can
keep it and you open up the towel it's a
[ __ ] up front across the thing he
bought it up lobbed it in his face
i was thinking bro you're chatting the
most yeah yeah yeah and then teddy was
coming from heights and he said fam all
this chat it's done yeah he was giving
it chest if you had he was giving it in
the press conference yeah chest okay man
said just chit-chatting it's done yeah
it's a scrap thing now it's done is he
beefed up since the last fight is that
obviously oh my god
okay let's say let's say um no
just to clarify no nah but he's giving
it chat yeah he said all this all this
all this is done bro it's a scrap thing
and that's it
so rock up to the fight now
his head got pinned about
this horseradish bread this wasabi guy
pinged his head about
really every chance this is the ticket
is dread so i'm not gonna lie deji's
technique stepped up up yeah he came
with a southpaw stance yeah dropped his
shoulder on some mayweather thing yeah i
think you're all right and he's got he
got a good stance he's coming in with
that papa the step back slip step
forward the quick job i'm thinking i
stepped his [ __ ] up yeah homeboy
stepped his [ __ ] up okay as soon as
you know when uh you're a kid a man gave
you one of them flinches and you and you
back up yeah wasabi had him on the ropes
really he's given one of them like not
even a starter did give him one of them
did his elbow was here covering his eyes
and then alex would use that to just run
up on him yeah pump him to pieces
firm every time
every chance deji got he will grab him
and squeeze it
but because he's shorter than the alex
right his chin would be on his shoulder
like this and it looked like he was in
his earphone like you're stronger
[Music]
you're strong
please please please please stop stop
stop what was that again um
aj
was it dylan white
it may have been dylan white maybe or
maybe it wasn't was it yeah no yeah
yeah i don't know i can't remember who
it was but when he dropped he dropped
him and he hit him double the double
bounce on his arse you're stronger
you're stronger
that was digi yeah fam grabbed him for
dear life chin on his traps and said
you're strong you're stronger
that's all i saw round after round after
round
he got twisted
came online afterwards and said
to the general public and i'm sorry
[Laughter]
came online and said i'm sorry twitter
fam you believed in me and i'm sorry
and then during their fight i'm sure it
was their fight i'm pretty sure yeah
during their fight some random don
from the general public jumped in the
ring
from jumped in the ring and was just
chatting running around during the fight
during the fight bro this is
embarrassing man the whole thing was
embarrassing bro jumped in the ring was
screaming all sorts fam
when i say security lobbed him out of
the ring over the ropes he must have
landed on his head
he was up in the thing
secretly ran up there found [ __ ]
launched him over the ropes this is
that's his program oh oh he deserves to
be hospitalized i don't know what he was
playing at i don't know what the [ __ ] he
was playing let's get his five seconds
of fame yeah bro literally um
and then the the last one i watched was
i think the co-main event i think deji
was the main co-main event and then
kenny versus
faze temper
was the other co-main event i think
um so facebook is like
he's like uh in facebook face clan is
like a group of youtubers usually like
game and streamers and stuff like that
um
they've got cake as a community they've
got cake yeah yeah um
and um
yeah apparently someone told me that he
like
owns the thing he doesn't even do
youtube anymore but his temper brother
like runs the face clown anyway yeah uh
and then king kenny versus him so this
was high top to be like the most skill
based match up
i've seen king kenny spa and when i said
i watched the one that um they did with
chunks of blood this was a few years ago
i've never seen that he couldn't no he
couldn't do much so i'm interested
if you're saying it's meant to be the
main thing i'm interested in
i think it was him versus nico oh swear
his name nico the brother the tall slim
brother i think so they're clan yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think they've they
fought or was here oh nico or whatever
his name is yeah
yeah yeah and kenny wasn't
he wasn't about it
he just wasn't yeah
he just wasn't so
you know what i mean like there's no
offense to him he just wasn't about it
he lacked so much yeah yeah yeah so i'm
interested here yeah yeah so um
so i found
it was it was poised to be the most
skilled thing yeah it didn't look skill
to me
but you don't you can't put too much
earnest on that man to be elite level
fighters at the end of the day this is
not what they do
and they're just doing it tonight
um he was on this to he he was coming
out with some stretch out thing
some stretch out things right fighting
i'm not gonna lie
when the the temper brother was throwing
a couple one twos
katie was here
fam there was a couple times you know um
pinball machines yeah
that was his head top i swear a couple
of times where that was his head
he was covering up i said
his head was here
he looked like a churchill dog
was like
honestly he must have been clenching his
neck yeah because you know when you
clench your neck tight and then like say
if you're on a roller coaster yeah
you know when you're a roller coaster
and the thing is swinging corners and
you're trying to stay rigid and your
head's like this
that was kenny in the thing from when
faze brother was tapping his head he was
clenching his neck yeah and he's here if
i jolted his brain was jolting bro yeah
yeah yeah
yeah teeth clenched everything yeah it
was long for him
overall he won the fight oh is it but
there's been controversy about that win
there's been controversy about that win
so a lot of men are saying yeah it was
it was a fixed team was it all for sorry
is it all for pride like winners or did
i get p
yeah i'm sure they get p okay
there was a pay-per-view event there's
pm there's p involved i'm not doing that
for pride of course because
as far as i'm concerned none of them
have nothing
[Laughter]
apart from maybe salt pups
none of them have anything they should
be proud of after that
so um yeah bro that whole thing was a
[ __ ] joke and after that this whole
little era in my opinion needs to get
away
[Music]